hey t hey Klick einmal du bist der beste
Youtuber den es nur gibt und dann kommt
meine Frag also wie kommst du auf diese
Charaktere wie Sandra oder
Sasa Sandra die wie ist mir die
eingefallen ich weiß es nicht mehr genau
man guckt sich so Leute an und man denkt
dann so ja die haben irgendwie ein
kleinen
einerchen
und und deswegen so eht die einfach man
man guckt sich die Leute an und denkt da
kannst du irgendwas draus machen
irgendwas rausfiltern und das ein
bisschen übertrieben darstellen ja und
so entsteht dann Sandra und Sascha ich
weiß ja gar nicht wer sascha ist Sascha
sieht man ja nie den gibt's ja
eigentlich gar nicht
ja